der achte und äußerste planet des
sonnensystems ist neptun und dieser
gasriese mit einem durchmesser von knapp
50.000 kilometer gibt uns immer noch
große rätsel auf zwar haben schon die
aufnahmen der raumsonde voyager 2 vor 30
jahren gezeigt dass in seinen oberen gas
schichten kräftige wirbelstürme toben
doch noch immer ist unklar wie genau sie
entstehen jetzt hat das hubble
weltraumteleskop einen neuen mysteriösen
dunklen wirbelsturm auf dem netto effekt
kommen wir dem phänomen damit jetzt auf
die spur kriegs um science-fiction
hier gibt es täglich spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal nur dann und
nur dann verpasst er keins herzlich
willkommen den neuen laut nasa äußerst
mysteriösen wirbelsturm auf dem neptun
hat das hubble-weltraumteleskop schon im
herbst 2008 10 entdeckt doch erst jetzt
hat die nasa diese entdeckung öffentlich
gemacht und der sturm ist nicht ohne
er tobt auf der nördlichen hemisphäre
des neptun und wird wohl mehrere jahre
andauern so vermuten es zumindest die
nasa fachleute um den wirbelsturm
heroben sind wolken in hell weiß so
button
diese entstehen durch die aufgewirbelte
luft die abkühlt und einfriert nach
vermutung von experten und expertinnen
könnte es sich hierbei um kondensierte
methan handeln vergleichbar mit dem
wasserdampf auf der erde dazu heißt es
auch von seiten des space telescope
science institute diese wolken einen
solchen wolken mit pfannkuchen förmigen
erscheinungsbild die man sieht wenn luft
über den bergen auf der erde
aufgewirbelt wird
solche stürme auf dem neptun sind eher
selten auch wenn der planet wohl einer
der wichtigsten orte unseres
sonnensystems ist es handelt sich hier
um die insgesamt sechste sturm auf dem
neptun den wir menschen mitbekommen
haben vier davon wurden bereits durch
das hubble-teleskop aufgespürt diesmal
wurde der wirbel bei
routineuntersuchungen entdeckt dazu die
nasa diese bilder sind teil einer reihe
von hubble schnappschüssen von neptun
und uranus die die wettermuster auf
diesen weit entfernten kalten planeten
aufzeichnen
doch das seltsame daran alle bisher
beobachteten wirbel unterscheiden sich
extrem und zwar in form größe und
wanderungsbewegungen ihre einzige
gemeinsamkeit ist wo lediglich dass sie
nur einige jahre existieren anders als
der große rote fleck des jupiters der
schon seit jahrhunderten existiert doch
der aktuelle wirbelsturm ist nicht ohne
er soll laut nasa einen durchmesser von
6.800 meilen also umgerechnet knapp
11.000 kilometern haben
zum vergleich der durchmesser der erde
beträgt 12.000 700 kilometer die ersten
beiden wirbelstürme konnten bereits 1989
entdeckt werden damals fand nämlich der
erkundungsflug der nasa wolter zwei
sonder stadt spannend war auch die
untersuchung eines wirbelsturms durch
das hubble-teleskop über einen längeren
zeitraum hinweg und zwar von 2015 bis
damals ging man davon aus dass sich der
sturm von 2017 am neptun etwa auflösen
würde
doch die simulationen der fachwelt lagen
komplett falsch der sturm zog in die
entgegengesetzte richtung er verblasste
langsam als er richtung südpol zog das
macht noch einmal deutlich dass wir
tatsächlich kaum etwas über diese wirbel
wissen weder wie sie sich bilden noch
wie schnell sie sich drehen doch die
nasa ist optimistisch und glaubt das
rätsel bald lösen zu können denn schon
bilder aus der vergangenheit zeigten
eine erhöhte wolken aktivität auf den
neptunes und das ist die
schlussfolgerung der nasa dazu die
bilder zeigen dass sich die stürme
vermutlich tiefer in der atmosphäre des
neptuns entwickeln und erst sichtbar
werden wenn der sturm sein höhepunkt und
höhere lagen erreicht große hoffnung
wird weiterhin das hubble-teleskop
gesetzt es besitzt die notwendige
know-how kameras und die auflösung um
das noch so unberechenbare wetter auf
dem neptun sichtbar machen zu können
so sollen die äußeren planeten auch
weiterhin langfristig beobachtet und
analysiert werden laut nasa könnten
dadurch atmosphärische trends
nachvollzogen werden und verbliebene
geheimnisse dieser fernen welt gelüftet
werden die spannung bleibt also auf dem
jupitermond europa wurden geysiren
nachgewiesen er gilt damit als einer der
aussichtsreichen kandidaten für leben
darf hier draufklicken anschauen und
abonnieren
bis dann bleibt dran